all right so this is the new 13-inch m2
macbook pro and i don't think anyone
should actually buy it wait what yeah no
i think it's a great computer first of
all don't get me wrong but with the
introduction of the m2 macbook air and
the existence of the 14-inch m1 pro
macbook pro they've managed to squeeze
any reason for this machine to exist at
this price
to basically zero nobody should buy it
yeah but nobody that i mean that seems
pretty harsh matter of fact i'm here let
me challenge you on that
this is a great computer changed my mind
okay well let's just start with the
design so apple's been going through
their laptop lineup upgrading everything
with this new square shape larger
displays with thinner bezels getting rid
of the touch bar and actually adding
ports but this particular refresh didn't
get any of that so this brand new laptop
looks exactly the same as the m1 macbook
pro from two years ago which looks
exactly the same as the 13-inch intel
macbook pro with the touch bar that
dropped in 2016 because it is exactly
the same i could give him sustainability
credit i guess for recycling an old
design and apparently using the same
boxes from the m1 macbook pro just with
new stickers on them but yeah this exact
shell design is literally six years old
and is starting to look kind of out of
place now next to apple's other
notebooks like can you imagine any other
company trying to reuse a six-year-old
design like you trying to tell me a
2016 asus laptop re-release would fly
today like a six-year-old xps drop like
that's wild yeah but this isn't that
like let me tell you uh if it ain't
broke don't fix it and i'm not just
saying that like this is a really good
laptop design all metal jacket a plus
hinge and let me just remind you you
reviewed it and you loved it the screen
was bright and high resolution still is
the speakers were best in class still
are great track pad and keyboard and by
the way some people do really like the
touch bar you said so yourself it might
not do a whole lot but it still has its
few advantages okay but that that is in
a vacuum like that's the thing by itself
i would agree with you this computer is
a perfectly good laptop buy it but as
soon as you put it alongside the new
macbook air which is basically the same
price it's actually worse at basically
everything like i got hands on time with
the new m2 macbook air that's about to
come out next month right the air has a
larger display with thinner bezels and
in that notch there's a new 1080p webcam
instead of a 6 year old 720p webcam it
has magsafe with a color matching cable
which enables fast charging and
essentially frees up an extra port since
that's one more usb-c port that you're
not plugged into and it's all in a
package that's thinner weighs less and
is basically the same price so why would
you buy this macbook pro how is it even
pro anymore you know what that's a good
question why would you buy
this pro
the answer i think first of all is it is
the cheapest pro in the lineup
technically it's true but really the
reason you get this over the air is the
thicker chassis supports active cooling
so it's got a fan and all the benefits
that come with that i mean the
benchmarks are in and to the surprise of
absolutely no one it's pretty clear that
this m2 chip is awesome it's living up
to the 10 to 20 percent better
multi-core cpu performance and even more
impressively the two extra gpu cores
over m1 is giving it 30 to 40 percent
better gpu performance which is
basically the only area where you could
say m1 was lacking so this is awesome
for any applications that lean on the
gpu everything's faster final cut is
faster premiere is faster any games you
might play are all faster and the cherry
on top is it has a dramatically improved
media engine same one from the higher
end chips actually so you can actually
pull off some heavier final cut pro
edits so for something like that while
you're in a program for hours and things
are getting hot okay that's when you
need the fans to kick in keep
performance high
longer than the macbook air ever could
no throttling so if you've got the
sustained workloads and the long
performance stuff you should get the m2
macbook pro no no those people should
just go straight to the 14 inch m1 pro
macbook pro just go straight to the big
brother look if you know you're going to
be doing workloads and things that the
macbook air can't handle
then you should just go to the actually
pro laptop the upgraded machine
if you're going to get a nice laptop and
you want to do extra performance stuff
on it you weren't going to get the
baseline macbook pro right you were
going to bump it up first of all because
you want at least 16 gigs of memory
right and second of all because the 256
gigs of baseline pro storage is kind of
insulting and that version has
particularly clipped ssd performance
worse than even the m1 macbook pro so to
get to one terabyte and 16 gigs you're
already looking at like 1900
for this machine
at that point
just get the 14 inch pro because that
laptop is on another level of
performance i mean don't get me wrong
it's absolutely awesome to see the jump
from m1 to m2 and that's going to enable
a ton more great stuff for the most
popular laptop for the everyday baseline
users but if you zoom out there's still
a big difference in performance when
moving up to the higher end chips m1 pro
and then m1 max the amount of additional
performance you get for the extra two to
three hundred dollars is massive if
that's what you really want that's what
you should get plus you get a much
better brighter mini led high refresh
rate screen too
and the webcam and the notch is way
better much better speakers and actually
get some ports while you're at it so i
just i don't know you shouldn't get a
literal worse version of all of those
things i mean two to three hundred bucks
isn't nothing
i mean
it's not zero but like
i don't know really squeezes this new
macbook pro quite a bit and plus you
can't get around the fact that it's it's
literally worse at all those things i
think you're forgetting something uh oh
really the macbook pro has studio
quality microphones while the macbook
air does not um
i mean so technically they both are
listed as having triple microphone
arrays with beamforming it's just apple
chose to call the one in the macbook pro
studio quality it might have a slight
difference but really are you gonna pay
extra for that and then sacrifice all
this other stuff okay i think there is
one redeeming factor
and what is that
battery
the macbook pro has surprisingly
excellent battery life better than i
think pretty much all of us expected we
saw the 20 hours of video playback
quoted on stage but in real world use
this might be the best battery life in
any modern laptop we've ever seen
there's people out here getting 16 to 20
hours of actual real world use the
verge's laptop reviewer monica wrote a
hilarious piece about how long it took
her to run down a battery and across the
board it's a tremendously long performer
so if you want the best battery in any
laptop get this one okay so that is
awesome to see
but at the same time those other laptops
already have great battery life too so
you're not trying to spend
just to get a slightly better battery
and then sacrifice all those other
things we talked about
it's really quite a small difference uh
so the ideal customer for this new
macbook pro m2
is somebody who just needs a slightly
better sustained performance than the
new macbook air and is willing to
sacrifice screen size webcam speakers
ports thickness and weight to get it
or someone who is literally about to buy
the 13-inch m1 macbook pro
enterprise
yep enterprise that's it
you